[Musique]
je prends ça pour un oui quoi la bague
le monde toujours la mort de superman
les actes de violence de guerre et de
terrorisme se multiplient j'ai fait un
rêve
c'était la fin du monde
une ovation
je crois qu'il ya autre chose
[Musique]
de plus sombre
on demandait des gens qu'on ne connaît
pas de risque et leur fils l'homme fort
il est encore plus seul a déjà entendu
ça c'est pas salé dicton c'est le
contraire de ce que dit le dicton
diviser pour n'est pas assez fort
[Musique]
le monde a besoin de superman
je lui ai fait une promesse non
c'est pour ça que je faisais rennais
[Musique]
la balade est pas fini tu as toi tu
mais
[Musique]
trop fort c'est votre pad signal c'est
votre
au début c'est votre signal qui dit
qu'il fouillait